now the 11 statues in Parliament Square
in London not one is of a woman as
Nelson Mandela Gandhi Churchill and
Israeli but now petition calling for a
statue of the suffragettes to join the
ranks has gained more than 68 thousand
signatures so is it time to have such a
statue in Parliament Square well joining
me now to discuss the comedian Kate
Smurf wait and the writer Charlotte Gill
thank you both for joining us ladies at
you first Kate Why should there be a
suffragette represented in Parliament
Square what's the case for well I mean
it it's fairly straightforward really
the the right for half of the population
to vote to be involved in the political
process in our country is huge I mean
you know we're looking at a hundred
years since this was the big issue in
British politics and there are a huge
number of women who you know quite
literally put their lives on the line in
some cases and indeed in one case very
memorably lost her life there are women
who gave up their their whole lives
campaigning for this and it's such an
important thing for 52 percent of us in
this country that's the reason why we
get to be involved in politics and I
don't think it's really too much to ask
that we should commemorate this by
putting a statue in Parliament Square
even you know it essentially because you
mentioned some of the more notable guys
who have statues in Parliament Square
there are some guys there you know
George canning he was Prime Minister for
what four whole months
you know he's sort of almost there as a
statue because of what he might have
done rather than what he actually did I
think there's a good argument for saying
you know we've got loads of guys there
let's make sure the message that women
are as entitled to be a part of our
political discourse as men let's make
sure that we genuinely communicate that
and and one really obvious and clear way
of doing that is that when you go to
visit Parliament you don't walk past
eleven men you walk past at least one
woman I'm not you know I'm not even
asking for half the statues although I'd
quite like that I'm asking for one okay
Charlotte it seems a pretty clear case
doesn't it what are we too much to ask
for just one well I think the whole
problem with this campaign is it really
shows the rise of arbitrary feminism in
other words looking for problems that
don't really exist looking for things to
do when women real feminists should be
focusing on real
problems you know things like
gender-based violence for instance the
fact of the matter is that a week ago no
wouldn't cared that there wasn't a
statue of a woman on Parliament Square
and it took Caroline creado Perez he is
running this campaign to go for a jog
with her dog and go oh that's strange
there's not a woman so so I want to know
why why all the fuss now for many of us
you know obviously Parliament Square has
a very important part of London and the
UK but it's not where we're hanging out
you know it's generally full of
politicians and tourists and and people
walking around that area aren't really
thinking about gender equality you know
mostly how do I get to Hamleys hmm Kate
feminists should be concentrating on
bigger and better things well there's
two things there firstly the idea that
that people who thinking about politics
won't won't be thinking about gender
equality well that that's kind of the
problem isn't it I want people who think
about politics to think about gender
equality because there's some of those
other issues that Caroline mentions I
would I would like to get those further
up the list I would like to have those
addressed and I'd like to have those
talked about and I think that if we're
not thinking about gender equality when
we think about politics then that is the
root of the problem but also I mean to
be quite frank with you this the start
of what was said there about feminist
need to concentrate on other things like
that to me that's kind of the most
stupid thing I've heard all day I didn't
ask I didn't get a phone call this
morning that said what would you like to
talk about on the news today and if I
had had such a phone call I would have
said we need to let in 3,000
unaccompanied child refugees I would
have said where you need to stop selling
off the NHS I would have said we need to
do something about the education system
and make sure that it doesn't end up
being run by carpet companies I would
have given you a great big list of
things and the idea of sitting there and
going well you're focusing on the wrong
things but quite the contrary I like
many many feminists around the country
I'm campaigning on a huge number of
issues that affect real people's lives
and I think that you know the fact that
us feminists are not taken seriously
enough by Parliament you know why is
that what's going on why aren't the
politicians listening more to
campaigners like me and well one of the
reasons is because women's voices are
not taken seriously and what's driving
that well one of the things driving that
is that when we talk about politics your
other guests immediately says you know
that's got nothing to do with with
under equality well it has it's got
everything to do with gender equality
and the treatment of refugees has
everything to do with gender equality
and the way that our health services
been treated has everything to a gender
equality and education service all of
this stuff has everything to do with
gender equality because these are all
issues that affect women and right here
and all around the world and so I think
I think it's kind of churlish it's what
I would call priorities trolling it's
you know it's like asking the Asthma
society why they don't do much more
about motor neurone disease the fact is
there are lots and lots of important
issues if she thinks something is more
important than this brilliant she should
get started in working on it I'll be
glad to sign a petition I'll join your
protest I'll be all over it but to get a
word in anyways that's that's daft and
churlish
I mean it's not a fair point Charlotte
that you know you say that there are no
one there is not really a problem you
don't really notice it there are bigger
and better things to focus about but if
there were women there wouldn't that
encourage more women to get into
Parliament would a statue make a
difference do you think well as we've
established Caroline creado Perez he's a
very intelligent and politically astute
woman only noticed last week that there
was the statue missing so it showed it
just shows that not many people are
paying attention to the first place and
you know on the other hand she might say
for men
do they feel inspired by by the male
statues there but the fact is that a lot
of people were baffled by who some of
them are so I think it's a really
simplistic argument to say to say that
oh someone will see a statue going
around Parliament Square I've suddenly
been inspired to follow their dreams and
if they didn't have the statue then that
we won't have gender inequality which is
just bizarrely
reductionist and pedantic and the fact
is you know I I understand what Kate's
saying you know there are lots of little
things that matter in the fight for
feminism but it's a massive energy trade
I mean sure you'll get a guardian column
if you want to do this sort of campaign
but why you know it's just such a waste
of energy signatures there already
hasn't there been Charlotte Kate do you
think women deserve a statue in
parliament do you think we've actually
done enough since we got the vote all
those years ago there's been one female
Prime Minister you know that only a
third of MPs are women around the third
of the cabinet female have we tried hard
enough do we deserve a spot
globally women do something like
two-thirds of the work so the idea of
that we have to do something special to
earn a spot in Parliament Square to earn
you know one statue next to eleven
statues of men I mean I mean I sort of
to be honest I find the question
obnoxious and offensive like what do
women need to do to earn their place you
know as if as if we somehow have to work
hard with everybody else women let me
finish they women fought and fought to
the point of losing their lives
sacrificed their whole life to get women
the vote this is not what else did you
want I mean I mean you know I mean if a
woman was willing to sacrifice her
entire life for this cause I don't
understand how much more she could have
given so have women done enough well if
if if a woman's whole life isn't enough
to say that she deserves some
recognition to say that she deserves
more recognition for example than George
canning who as we've established was
prime minister for a whole four months
then then I think that's a daft question
the fact is women around the world work
incredibly hard in all sorts of fields
and they're almost consistently under
recognized for it and not given the
credit that they deserve and I think you
know I think to sort of to even ask the
question whether women deserve one
statue out of a potential 12 in
Parliament Square well it's just
obnoxious we deserve half the world
because we are half the world and that
you know we do we do more than half the
work and we deserve to be recognized for
all the stuff that we do from the women
right at the top you've mentioned of
course you know we did have a female
prime minister but also the women right
their way through the system who are the
people keeping this country going and
doing the vast majority of the caring
work and all other kinds of important
stuff that goes on around our country
and running businesses and all this
stuff and the idea that that we do all
that hard work and somebody's going to
sit there and ask whether we really
deserve a whole statue it makes me want
to swear on it and I shall please don't
and I'll try to be equally as obnoxious
to Charlotte Gill I mean Charlotte we
you know we know that sexism is still
rife in all sorts of parts of society in
Westminster you know there been stories
in the news just the last few weeks
about MPs saying inappropriate things to
female journalists look at a female
statue outside the houses of parliament
perhaps
act as a perhaps a useful aid memoir to
some of the men in Parliament I mean I
just think in terms of what Kate says no
one's denigrating women's achievements
no one's saying that they haven't done
brilliant things they're just saying eh
it's the statute aren't there more
important things to worry about and be
why why now like why is everyone upset
about it now you know the statute all of
those eleven statutes have been up for a
while it just seems like looking for
something to complain about and I do you
think we've got bigger fish to fry and
write well okay then there's something
very important that you haven't met that
you've missed there's something very
very important because you say why now
and why is this important you know and I
hear this all the time about women's
rights well why you focused on this one
and why have we got to worry about it
now why can't this you know what let's
let's leave this kind of thing well
here's what you're misunderstanding when
we're campaigning for women's rights
they are rights so we should never be
asked which one to get first and we
should never be asked which one is more
important than the other they are right
there are things that we are entitled to
an equal representation is something we
are entitled to it is a right so the
right number of rights to have is all of
them and the right time to have them is
right now immediately because that is
what rights are they're not a privilege
they're not a little extra they're not a
bonus they're not a luxury they're a
right so we should have all of them and
we should have them now and if
somebody's getting up and campaigning to
change things and make things better and
to give us our rights then I think
everybody should get on board with the
idea of sitting on a TV show and saying
oh I don't know why we can't focus on
other things well great go home focus on
other things look I'm here I want to get
this one finished and then I'm ready to
move on to the next thing and the last
thing I need is you in my way slowing me
down so I can't get to the next thing
let's do the thing that's right and then
let's move on and save the rest of the
planet come on let's do it together
Charlotte I believe in you come on
Charlotte last thought to you okay I
mean you're basically putting words in
my mouth that I haven't said that you're
saying things like I don't believe in
women's right because because I think
energy of the ocean is right other than
sorry if it you've had your time but I
think the main problem a lot of feminism
focuses on societal messages there's
this big idea that statues are holding
women back if they don't see the right
thing they're going to be suddenly
suddenly reduced and this victimizers
women in this
and this makes them feel more dissonant
victimizes women chuckles you very
briefly put last there isn't that true
there isn't a statue of Thatcher in
Parliament Square yet either I mean do
you not think the first female Prime
Minister you don't think she should be
marked in Parliament Square I dunno I I
mean I'm not as fast about the statue as
everyone else I haven't really given
great horse to you about it what seems
like a debate we're having is I don't
see the show that's actually at the
finish
why do you the great need for the
statute especially when no one has
really noticed least not Caroline creado
Perez for a very long time that there
was a women statue missing so I just
can't see the impetus in and going over
this in great detail and finally very
briefly case there is a statue of a
Toberman in bankís the suffragettes all
are represented she's a fighter pilot
aureus I mean yeah I have a big problem
with that but the issue is that we've
got two people here and I think we
should put a statue of a suffragette in
Parliament Square and Charlotte thinks
that we which sort of shouldn't bother
because you know it's just not that
important so when we're talking when
it's not it is not the case that
Charlotte thinks we shouldn't have won
because it would be awful and it would
make the world a worse place the fact is
some people aren't that bothered that's
fair enough they're entitled to be not
that bothered what they're not really
entitled to do is to tell me what I
should or shouldn't be bothered about as
it happens I think there's a great big
list of things that would make life
better and fairer for women in Britain
and Charlotte mentions you know that
nobody seems to have noticed people walk
past the neurons mentioned it but isn't
that the point that you don't notice
when women are absent from these things
you forget that this is just how this is
how things have always worked and
actually it's not how things have a way
in the future gonna be better and we
should start with this Kate Smith wait
and Charlotte Gill thank you both very
much are you bothered
let us know your thoughts I'm sure some
of our viewers will have some thoughts
on it keep your votes coming in at Jane
Secor sky